was sind deine hobbys
ich spiele gitarre
ich war
ich fahre ski
ich mache gern yoga
ich lese gern
ich trainiere oft im fitnesscenter
ich mag fußball
machst du oft sport
nein ich mache selten sport
ja ich mache oft sport
ja ich spiele jeden dienstag und
donnerstag tennis
als was arbeitest du
ich arbeite als ingenieur
ich habe einen neuen job als sanitär
ich arbeite momentan nicht
ich bin arbeitslos
vom beruf billig anwalt
von beruf bin ich anwalt
was ist ein beruf
was ist dein beruf
ich bin informatiker
mein beruf ist lehrer
hast du studiert
nein ich habe nicht studiert
nein ich habe
studiert
ich habe
das leder gemacht
ich habe berufslehre gemacht
ja ich habe informatik studiert
ja ich studiere medizin
hast du kinder hast
du kinder
ja ich habe einen sohn
ja ich habe eine tochter
[Musik]
ja ich habe zwei söhne
ja ich habe zwei töchter
[Musik]
nein ich habe keine kinder
hast du geschwister
ja ich habe einen bruder
ja ich habe eine schwester
ja ich habe zwei brüder
ja ich habe zwei schwestern
nein ich bin ein einzelkind
bis du verheiratet
bis do verheilt
nein ich bin nicht verheiratet
nein ich bin ledig
ja ich bin verheiratet
nein ich bin geschieden
hast du einen freund
ja ich habe einen freund
nein ich habe keinen freund
aus so eine freundin
hast du eine freundin
ja ich habe eine freundin
nein ich habe keine freundin
hast du ein auto
nein ich habe kein auto
ja ich habe ein auto
hast du hunger
[Musik]
nein ich habe keinen hunger
ja ich habe hunger
kannst du schwimmen
nein ich kann nicht schwimmen
ja ich kann gut schwimmen
kannst du gut kochen
nein ich kann nicht gut kochen
ja ich kann sehr gut kochen
wie fühlst du dich
wie willst du dich
ich fühle mich nicht gut
ich fühle mich gut
wie schmeckt dir das essen
es schmeckt mir sehr gut
es schmeckt
nicht
es schmeckt mir nicht
was liest du
ich lese ein buch
ich lese die nachrichten
was isst du gern
ich esse gern teigwaren
ich esse gern kartoffeln
ich esse gern reiße ich
esse gern reis
brauchst du
[Musik]
ja ich rauche manchmal
nein ich brauche nicht
[Musik]
nein ich rauche nicht
wie gefällt dir das lied
es gefällt mir sehr gut
welche musik hörst du gern
ich höre gern techno
wie gefällt dir der film
er gefällt mir nicht so gut
gäste oft an konzerte
[Musik]
gehst du oft an konzerte
ja ich gehe oft dann konzerte
nein ich gehe selten an konzerte
spielst du ein instrument
ja ich spiele gitarre
nein ich spiele kein instrument
kannst du gut singen
ja ich kann gut singen
nein ich kann nicht gut singen
nein ich kann gut singen
worauf freust du dich
ich freue mich auf die ferien
ich freue mich auf den urlaub
ich freue mich auf das wochenende
ich freue mich auf deinen besuch
ich freue mich auf meinen lohn
ich freue mich auf meinen geburtstag
ich freue mich darauf dich zu treffen
ich freue mich darauf im restaurant zu
essen
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video